The joe rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you've got to Joe rogan.net,
click on the link and enter in the code name Rogan.
You get 15% off the number one sex toy for men.
Daniel Pinchbeck is in the house.
Ladies and gentlemen,
strapping and experience.
We're going to get crazy
[inaudible].
It's taken a long ride
down.
Some of my favorite schools of thought with this guy here.
Daniel Pinchbeck is a author.
If you'd never heard of him,
he's got a great book called breaking open the head and another one called,
uh,
2012 the return of Queso Quadel is that,
how do I say it?
Right?
Good enough.
Close enough.
[inaudible] and I'm just an all around.
Fascinating dude.
Thanks for coming by,
man.
I'm sorry you got stuck in traffic,
but it's almost appropriate because you're sort of a little bit of a doom and
gloom end of civilization,
sort of a dude and there's a giant power outage in la that fuck traffic upside
down.
Well,
yeah.
Now that I know that I feel better about the situation.
Yeah.
Do you though?
Oh,
finally.
Some apocalyptic shit's happening and while I'm here,
perfect.
In New York,
we just had a hurricane and an earthquake and a one week,
uh,
I moved here when the earthquake happened.
I moved here like only like a month after the earthquake in [inaudible] 94
happened.
And it was this feeling of humility in La that I liked.
Like when I first got here,
I was like,
people are seem kind of shook up,
but they seem pretty friendly,
you know,
sort of almost like,
any sort of a natural disaster does to any big group of people,
you know,
they uh,
what are you doing there buddy?
I'm looking at your Alpha brain.
Do you want some,
what is it?
It's own nootropics.
It's vitamins for cognitive function.
Sure.
We're not going to go get brighter.
It's 1.5 million people in power right now.
I think it was in Los Angeles,
in Los Angeles right now,
which is kind of crazy.
But yeah,
it is crazy.
That's a lot of fucking people.
We sell those.
I'll get you a bottle.
Those things,
man.
We just started,
uh,
putting those out on a,
on@dotcomonnit.com.
And what it is is,
uh,
there's a lot of different things that people take to improve mental function
and they just put the highest ingredients together and started a,
started selling it.
Nice.
It's fascinating stuff man.
You know,
the,
the science of it is a little sketchy.
A lot of people call bullshit,
but I think it works.
Works for me,
man.
Even if it's just a placebo effect.
I'll take all the lies that you tell me if I believe them.
It seems like it works to me too.
Well,
the dreams or no question you,
you,
you take them,
you have this fucking,
these crazy vivid rememberable dreams.
It's very unusual.
And supposedly it's because of Coleen.
Is that how you saying?
Is that the,
the nutrient,
I believe you said it's called Coleen,
but apparently it's known to stimulate dreams.
It gives you fucking weird,
creepy,
memorable dreams.
I've got a weird dream of battle Werewolf and a gorilla having sex and I was
trying to be quiet and get out of the room before they realized I was there
because you,
I was last night
I was laying in bed and I was looking up your books on Amazon and uh,
the one cover he has is so trippy.
I actually spent a good time just scrolling up and down on my browser.
Just looking at the code.
Which one?
Over the head?
I think so.
And the one that has the mushroom in the middle and then it's just like,
it was fucking awesome.
I,
that's how stone it was the last time you're,
you're here
when this is,
what if this really was going down?
Like right now in Los Angeles.
Are you prepared?
Because I know you're a big 2012 advocate and I've talked to you about,
well,
I'm just that of burning man,
so at least I have my flashlight and Kevin [inaudible].
Did you just leave burning man?
Yeah,
three days ago.
Wow.
I was it,
it was great.
Now you're like my age,
right?
45.
I'm 44.
Do you not tired of those,
those crazy hippies yet really nutty ones,
you know,
whatever.
I mean,
I,
I like the whole scene.
I mean,
it's all sorts of genius people.
They're actually like a very,
like,
not just hippies but the heads of all the technology companies.
I had to debate with them Google exact cause,
a,
he was a yoga practitioner and you know,
just,
I have lots of great conversations where they are.
I mean it's all the,
you know,
the psychedelic community.
And I spent a lot of time with this woman who runs the women's visionary
Congress and my friend John Perry Barlow who wrote lyrics for the grateful dead
and it started electronic freedom foundation.
Um,
it's actually an amazing,
uh,
you know,
brain trust of,
of human oddities and eccentric fossils.
I believe that.
But there's also a lot of douchebags and you've got to wade through them.
And when your,
what you are is like this figurehead for this psychedelic movement and sort of a
lot of ways.
So you must get a lot of crackpots.
And when I say Douche bags,
it's not their fault.
I didn't just say us a lot of it,
there's a lot of crazy,
she didn't have one,
a douchebag experience and all every,
a lot of people did come up to you and whoever who was cool who would read my
books or seen the film and people were extremely like respectful and I still
kind of like,
I'm like moving like people tell me,
people told me that the books had affected them or impacted their lives.
Sure.
What I mean,
every dead show I've ever been to or any fish show I've ever been,
it was never been douche bag.
So I was think you would think that there'd be a shitload distract.
Everyone has like this positive vibe to them.
So everyone,
even if there are a douche bag,
they still have like this underlining.
Yeah.
I'm like a happy and in love.
I want to give you love and positive energy.
It seems like the whole scene and stuff like so I just have a negative idea.
I think so.
I think you're like carbon right now.
I lived in boulder for a walking,
became very terrified of him.
You're very east coast.
Before.
I was like so down with it and you're around them for wine like Todd.
So many people are fucking crazy.
You know everybody's crazy.
You know there's a Republican's a crazy right wing Christians or crazy.
I mean you look at the Republican convention,
you look at these,
these,
these speeches is,
so there's these,
these debates they're having,
it's like one nutty fucking person after nutty,
nutty person.
I mean it's this fucking,
the guy from California with a guy from the Massachusetts rather mitten Romney.
He's,
he's a Mormon.
I mean at a certain point in time you got to go,
come on man.
Really you believe that Joseph Smith,
this 14 year old kid found these golden tablets with the,
the last words of,
and only you
could read them cause you had a magic rock.
Really.
Okay.
Right.
At a certain point in time,
I mean,
how,
how does a guy like that allowed to even run for president?
Wow.
Is there certain things that you believe,
do you think that there should be a line that like someone completed signing go,
come on,
man,
this is crazy.
It was very hard to draw that line at this point.
I mean,
people,
you know,
believing in the Bible and so on,
it's hard enough.
We'll,
how about the 6,000 year people?
The people that really believe the earth is 6,000 years old.
There's a lot of them.
Sarah Palin,
she really believes that
a lot of people do.
I think you learned from that movie red state that that like everybody,
there's a this big center of the world that's really crazy and like fucking,
they believe crazy shit.
Like you can't,
even though I just watched that wild whites of West Virginia.
Oh,
I mean,
yeah,
those people believe probably things that you would be amazed.
I don't think that they're thinking about that.
They're just pill people.
Pill pop and people in partiers.
Yeah.
And you've seen that the wild and wonderful whites of West Virginia.
Nope.
It's a fascinating yet terrifying documentary that Johnny Knoxville put together
about this family in West Virginia.
That's completely crazy.
Hmm.
All there do.
Like they're just constantly committing crimes and selling pills and going on
rampages and get arrested and just a fascinating family.
That's just not living by the rules that you are.
I live by,
no,
now Berston burning man was sold out this year and it's just like,
I think the first time that it was ever sold out.
Did it seem like overly crowded or did it seem like,
why did they even put a,
uh,
they don't have a control over that.
It's the bureau of land management.
I think it's a,
actually,
because it counts as a city.
It's only allowed to go three Pr,
uh,
to grow 3% per year.
So it was growing from 51 to 54,000 or something like that.
Right.
Something like that.
So,
um,
so yeah,
I mean he could easily go up to 75 or a hundred thousand in terms of the space
there.
I mean,
they just keep,
they can just keep adding avenues and expanding it and so on.
Do you see any awesome art?
Did you see any like,
wow,
they took it to the next level type shit this year?
Um,
yeah,
there were,
so there was some beautiful stuff there.
There was a huge model of the Trojan horse,
which a 300 Greeks and white togas a drag for the gates and they blew it up in
spectacular fashion on Friday night.
There's lots of fun stuff.
Oh,
that sounds pretty fun.
I want to go so bad.
Like I talked about it and maybe fit 20 podcasts ago.
Like I was thinking about going and I'm mad at myself for not going.
Perceptions are always just going to be some really cool people did,
but just going to wade through some knuckleheads to get to them.
But you're sounding like it's not that way.
You're sounding like it's pretty positive overall.
Yeah,
I mean I'm,
you know,
I still like it.
No,
it's still not.
Okay.
What if this is December 21st,
2012 is the the big day and that's,
you know,
etched in stone and a lot of people's ideas about a lot of the shit that you
write about and a lot of the shit that people think of about the coming of the
next age.
If it rolls around and nothing happens,
then what?
Right.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
I,
once again,
we're actually,
people would have to look at whatever I said and read about it because I never,
I never particularly said that anything was going to happen.
Absolutely true.
Yes.
I mean,
absolutely having that,
you know,
on the other hand,
it seems to me that it's super clear that we're in
the middle of a transformation that,
that,
uh,
you know,
we can see now the global economy is buckling.
The planetary ecology is also buckling.
We've re we've hit peak oil.
A lot of the resources are in a serious depletion.
Um,
so yeah,
we're,
we're faced with,
with,
with an end game for the,
for the current global civilization that we're adding.
Is that peak oil thing been clearly established?
Yeah,
it's been very clearly established.
So everyone agrees it's not a debated thing.
Well,
I mean,
of course there's,
there's,
there's some debate and there's some misinformation.
There's a lot of,
there's a lot of money involved,
you know,
but if you look at what,
the,
the main geologists talk about,
and you know,
I mean,
it's prediction that was made back in the 70s.
That's why they're trying to get all this oil in Canada.
There's big protests had been happening on the White House lawn where Daryl
Hannah got arrested.
One of the NASA's top climate scientists get arrested and they're protesting
this extraction,
which is apparently incredibly inefficient.
Yeah,
of course.
But it's why we are,
we are,
you know,
in wars and,
Libya,
Afghanistan and Iraq and you know,
why we're trying to hold down the,
you know,
our,
our access to the,
to the remaining resources,
you know.
Um,
but yeah,
so,
um,
I never represent anticipated than anything exactly what happened on December
21st,
2012 although it certainly might.
Uh,
but I think that,
uh,
you know,
the,
what we need to do and when I tried to do and in my work up to this point is
really tried to take a big step back and look at our situation.
And factory in all sorts of stuff that,
you know,
the modern worldview was not really factoring in,
which for me includes Shamanism,
you know,
the DMT experience,
psychic experience in general.
Uh,
you know,
the kind of psychic capacities that actually many people are aware of that
happen all the time,
whether it's synchronicity or tube top of thing.
And so we were on the phone today.
We talked to,
I talked to you about it.
Like I was picking up your,
I picked up my phone and I was going through the contacts to find your number
and the phone rang and it was you.
I love that shit.
That's,
that's as creepy as it gets.
What are the,
there's a lot of minutes in a day,
more and more.
Right?
How do you know what I'm calling you,
man?
There's a lot of God demands in the day.
When was the last time I fucking called you?
I mean,
yeah,
you were supposed to be on the podcast,
the name.
We had emailed each other about it,
but we hadn't talked on the phone a long ass time.
That's a weird coincidence.
Right?
Well,
I mean,
you,
you think you could say that it's weird and creepy,
but then you kind of get past that point and you just kind of integrate it and
it's like,
okay,
there's somehow,
there's actually no one consciousness that's kind of working through all of us.
And,
and,
you know,
as time moves on in this period,
it seems like those synchronicities are speeding up and our,
and our psychic capacities are somehow and intensifying,
you know,
but,
but I will say that my one idea I'm working on for December 21st,
2012 is to utilize the date because now there's so much popular focus on it to
create a kind of global events,
which would be a kind of spectacle.
I'm working with the composers and a team from Cirque du Solei and they're kind
of putting together a concept for a show that would kind of celebrate humans
evolution,
you know,
mentees evolution to this present point and then ending with a synchronized,
uh,
peace meditation kind of global focus on unity with the idea that you could,
you could take that,
the energy for that that's pointed towards that day and there's so much fear
around that and anxiety and trepidation and actually make it into like the most
awesome thing possible where it's like,
well,
look where we've arrived at and look at our opportunities now to make a shift
and a jump into a new form of planetary civilization.
Well,
this is the,
the,
the clearest time in human history where the common person,
any person really has a direct influence over an incredible amount of people
with viral information,
with videos and with anything that you ride that really resonates with people.
You can hit an amazing amount of people now.
So a guy like you could get in touch with a bunch of other people who could do
exactly the same thing.
And a ripple effect can go on and it can hit millions and millions easy.
There's never been an opportunity to do anything like that.
Got,
we totally love to have you involved with our unified earth.
I'm not too sure.
Let's do see real sure.
Start to say I'm down.
Actually,
we're actually working at,
at the moment,
we're actually in
negotiation with the Mexican government to use a Chichen Itza,
Chichen Itza,
which is considered by the Mayans to be the heart of the Mayan world.
You know,
it would be the shit dude,
a Toby Keith concert at cheats in Eatsa gotta be the most ironic thing of all
time.
So he keeps his like this super raw,
raw American country music.
He's like,
[inaudible],
I'm gonna kick your ass.
You know?
He's like one of those guys.
He's,
but he's kind of,
he's a good singer.
I mean his,
he's got good songs,
but there are just,
some of them are like real knucklehead Rah Rah Rah songs.
I just think him on the fucking pyramids play in a concert might be one of the
most ironic things of all time.
Oh,
awesome.
America.
You can love it or leave it.
He had a good song about smoking weed with Willie Nelson though.
He's got good music.
He's got a good music.
I just think it would be funny.
Be Funny.
Yeah.
I'm scared to teach.
Teacher need to know.
Don't ever get a Mexican dream right.
That dream down right now.
It's on the Internet.
Now we can draw this dream for you.
You're right.
I should bullshit.
Never stopped dreaming going never stop to the eye.
I think
as as you do that things are moving in a certain direction and I wonder how much
people steer it.
You know how much things like this steer,
how much communication online steers it because it seems to me this is the only
time where people have been able to sort of like merge in this way globally on
their own and do it on a regular basis.
You know,
people are addicted to just going on Twitter,
addicted to communicating with people on message boards and on Facebook and
there,
there's,
there's an inner connectivity that's never existed before.
So an idea that the idea of a hive mind like influenced by anyone is way
different now than it's ever been in human history as far as we know,
right?
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Amazing Time,
Huh?
Yeah,
for sure.
I mean now one idea that a lot of um,
different people are kind of moving towards this idea that maybe humanities on
the verb of transition on the verge of transitioning into being kind of like a
super organism.
You know,
that we're kind of like coming to awareness of ourselves as a being in a
sentence,
you know,
and then we can,
begin to act more symbiotically rather than like parasitically or aggressively.
There was a really fascinating article recently written on creativity and how
people are always praising creativity and looking forward to getting new and
creative ideas,
but that other people's creativity actually makes people uncomfortable.
It makes people uncomfortable and uneasy.
And the idea that someone had come up with these ideas that they didn't,
you know,
and you know,
you,
you wonder if like the,
the really powerful push towards fundamentalism,
the really powerful push towards a 6,000 year old earth kind of Shit,
you know,
and follow the Bible kind of Shit is really the same thing as someone trying to
confined creativity.
They're trying to confine enlightenment will say reasonable.
I guess my feeling is basically,
you know,
we,
we live in a culture where there's,
um,
you know,
basically they're being,
people are being indoctrinated not to think they're being,
they're being indoctrinated by the,
the media,
the mainstream culture by the education system to be ignorant,
to not question,
to not develop their independent capacity of thoughts.
Are you okay,
but you saying this as an from the education system or he's saying this from the
media?
Yeah,
yeah.
From both,
I think.
But the media does not make you dumb,
right?
Oh yes it does.
Does it mean it makes people incredibly skewed,
makes you dumb.
You can't watch CNN.
I don't watch that stuff.
But mean if you,
did you think it would affect you?
Yeah,
but if I'm in a hotel room and I watched that stuff for a couple of days,
I feel like I'm having a lobotomy.
Whoa.
Really?
Just CNN or you can just see it as a program.
Things are,
um,
from my,
from my perspective,
they're basically,
I'm kind of holding the mass consciousness,
the planetary consciousness at a certain low level or low frequency where it's
passive consumerist fear based.
You know,
there's this violent activity,
very disjointed.
It creates a lot of frustration and anxiety.
There's no deeper analysis.
There's no attempt to create like a coherence,
you know,
understanding of what's happening.
And Yeah,
I could see your point.
That may be perhaps it isn't used to its utmost abilities or the capabilities
that we would have for it.
But I don't think that it's,
it's not a good form of entertainment.
I don't,
I don't think it has to be either or.
I feel like you could sit home and watch a fucking silly TV show and it doesn't
hurt you.
I mean,
I think this idea that we're helpless to media constantly bombarding us with
these images and ideals and that we,
we have to accept them.
I think that's silly.
And I think that honestly,
with the Internet,
with you look at the society that's growing out at the Internet,
look at like movements like anonymous,
look at Shit like this.
Things that have never happened before,
these giant groups moving forward.
And uh,
and,
and taking down websites and taking down companies that they feel have acted in
justly.
We didn't have,
no one's ever been able to do something like that before.
And he at Stevie,
if you want it,
oh,
it's going to have some coffee.
Thanks.
Uh,
yeah.
Well,
I mean,
so,
so we have two things that will be,
a number of things are happening simultaneously.
And that's another thing that's very interesting about our time is that things
are getting pretty complicated right now.
One problem with television in general is that it's designed to reduce
everything into tiny little soundbites.
You know,
when,
when Lincoln and Jefferson debated and the 1860s the debates lasted eight hours.
You know,
when we have a debate on TV,
each person gets like 36 seconds for this response.
23 [inaudible] were basically used to everything being spoonfed and dumbed down
to an absolute level of stupidity,
you know?
And basically the problem is that because our scenario on the planet is very
complex at this point,
we actually need to be able to,
you know,
articulate and analyze at a much deeper level,
you know?
So yes,
we have two things going on.
We have the one directional mass media,
which I really am convinced is basically a kind of a la bottomy machine that
anesthetize people into an ultimate state of idiocy and consumers passivity.
And then we have the development of this new interactive media,
which is having profound effects and will continue to have profound effects.
And if you go look at the history of the,
of media,
every time there's a new form of media that's very powerful,
it transforms,
you know,
the,
the society,
the political system,
the government changes,
everything.
You know,
you could never ever had an empire until you had a written code of laws that
could be distributed to the borders and beyond.
You could never have had a,
a modern representational democracy,
you know,
nation state unless you had the printing press,
which distributed enough,
you know,
materials that everybody could participate in.
Civic dialogues.
Now with this interactive technology potentially points towards a much deeper or
transition in our political and social paradigm,
uh,
potentially towards a away from centralized control hierarchy to more of a kind
of a distributed or direct democracy
and interconnectedness as human beings in general.
It's never,
no one's been this close to this many people just through online communication.
No one has ever had that kind of an influence before by such a wide variety of
people and ideas,
you know,
all come and watch,
look how incredibly knew it as.
I mean,
we're,
we're just adapting.
We're just,
we're just,
we're just like treading water trying to,
trying to catch up with the,
with this forest that,
that,
that our culture has a,
has unleashed,
unleashed
and it's good.
Or is it no,
or is it also just,
is it as awesome?
Well,
if you love change,
it's great.
I mean if you're somebody who had this,
you know Warner records,
you're probably scratching your head at this point.
The most fascinating conversation.
Yeah,
right.
I had the most fascinating conversation with a guy who was trying to say that
Google is bad and the idea of the Internet search is bad.
I go,
why?
He goes,
because you know,
it used to be if you wanted knowledge,
I had to go look for it.
I was like,
wow,
that might be the craziest fucking thing I've ever heard.
You think it should be hard to find that shit and she'd be hard.
You'd have to go to a library and look up the right bug.
It should take hours.
No,
you should be able to save your phone.
That's very much like people would talk about,
oh,
you shouldn't take a psychedelic cause.
It's like a shortcut to the mystical experience and of course the answer to that
is like,
you know what's right with a shortcut.
If I'm trying to get somewhere,
am I going to go like all around like a circuitous barring route or am I gonna
just take the frigging shortcut?
That reminds me of a joke.
Terence Mckenna used
to say that,
uh,
some guy practice a city of levitation for 40 years and figured out,
finally had a float and he came up to the Buddha and he said,
master,
I can walk across the water.
And the Buddhist said,
but the fairies only a nickel,
you know,
I mean,
take the fucking mushroom,
take a chance,
dude.
Take a take a shortcut.
Not only that,
the idea that you are independent from nature and then you don't need some help
in any way mean you're constantly getting help from nutrients and vitamins and
protein and all these different things he absorbed through nature.
But then when it comes to this that you think may or may not do something to
your mind,
you're not,
I can get there naturally
back to the Google search.
I mean,
yeah,
I think fat,
um,
you know,
the,
the fact that we now have so much knowledge and information,
you know,
at her disposal is an extraordinary thing,
you know?
But then the question is still how do we manage that?
What do we do with it and what type of,
you know,
society can we pull ourselves into?
Because at the moment what we have is,
is not going to last very much longer.
I liked what you said,
pull,
pull ourselves into,
because it's really,
it's going to have to be that because it's gonna you're gonna have to pull away
from the system that we have now that,
I mean,
especially the financial system and we've learned from when Ron Paul wanted the
audits of the bail outs and people found out how many trillions of dollars had
been sent into the,
this,
this whole idea of,
of bailouts and it,
where this tax dollars went.
I think a lot of people became really disillusioned and disenfranchised and,
and it had no connection to it.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
when,
when it happened,
did it make any sense to you when you were hearing him about the bailouts at any
of that make any sense to you and don't pay attention?
It's like,
it's,
it seems,
it seems like a system you can't fix.
So it seems like I,
you know,
it almost feels like trying to go against the machine that's currently in place
is,
it's so,
it's so intangible.
It's like so gigantic.
The financial system is completely and utterly corrupt and unrecognizable.
It's impossible to understand.
Right.
Well that's like,
I've been a bunch of the work I've been doing over the last few years.
I mean,
uh,
in the,
in the film,
actually we interviewed you for the film.
We didn't end up using your interview.
We just couldn't somehow splice it.
And I document online in 2012 time for change.
And we interviewed this guy,
Bernard,
Leah Tarr,
who was a,
he's an economist.
He was one of the architects of the euro.
You wrote a great book called the future of money.
And in that book he,
he,
you know,
and in our film also,
we discussed how the financial system is broken and it really doesn't matter at
this point who you put in control because it's still just like a car with no
brakes.
But that actually we're going to have to reinvent,
uh,
instruments for,
for exchanging value that actually have fundamentally different,
different value systems connected to them.
So for instance,
he proposes a currency which he closes the terror that has a negative interest
charge.
So it's a new trading currency,
big global trading currency that's indexed not to just a virtual abstraction
like our money currently is,
but actually it's index to a basket of real world goods and resources that
decline in value over time.
Cause most things do,
you know,
so,
so if the longer you held onto a terror,
the less it would be worth.
So instead of a gold standard,
it would be made based on a bunch of,
exactly.
I'm a bundle of resources that would include things cool.
And wheat and you know,
processed foods and unprocessed goods and so on.
And,
and as,
as,
as a summation of all of that,
it would,
it would actually decline in value.
It would have what's called a demo Raj charge.
So when people got a bunch of these terrorists through some business deal,
rather than seeking to hoard them or hold on to them,
that wouldn't work.
So they would eat best,
you know,
used by putting them back into circulation by sharing them or,
or,
or whatever.
So,
so,
um,
that's Leotard is concept and one of many concepts.
Uh,
we're actually publishing a book through my company evolver called sacred
economics by Charles Eisenstein.
It's actually already up on,
uh,
it's out on the Internet and you can get copies,
but he actually puts together a whole paradigm looking at the inevitability of,
of the financial system breaking down and really seeing that rather than just
having one monopoly of,
of a,
of a value exchanging instrument,
like money that's controlled by private banking and trusts,
you could really create a whole ecology of different ways of exchanging value
that would be used for different purposes.
Do you think that the government would ever allow something like that to
actually take place?
I mean it almost seems like trying to create a government inside the government.
Well,
I mean it's happened before I'm in for instance in the Depression and they
reissued a lot of local currencies.
It has also done in the 19th century.
Obviously you know that about a town in North Carolina or South Carolina that's
trying to do that right now.
Exactly.
Well I think that's,
that's,
that's definitely going to be on the horizon because people are not going to be
able to use this.
This,
there was a small town and they had their own currency in his town and there was
a debate about its legality.
And in fact if you look at,
um,
the bankruptcy of the government and the effects of a p Coyle and I'm all this
other stuff going on,
the capacity of the federal government to intervene into metal may actually
become radically reduced and the next and the next years because there's just
not going to be the money available for that kind of endless,
you know,
um,
effort.
Damn I face is melting
thinking about when you're saying,
yeah.
It was like just so much information I'm thinking about right now.
Well,
you know,
is it possible that none of this will actually happen that will sort of stumble
into the finish line?
No,
it's not possible.
It's not.
It's absolutely not possible.
So you think it's absolutely 100% that the society that we currently enjoy is
going to collapse?
Absolutely.
100%.
What kind of timeframe are you to have in it?
Uh,
you know,
could be a year,
could be 10 or 15 years.
Uh,
but,
but the point is to recognize that,
you know,
we're,
we're in it now.
I mean that,
that,
you know,
our,
our faith in capitalism,
capitalism is a system that has an inherent unstability to it.
And basically what it requires is constantly new markets that need to be turned
into money so you can keep the dynamics of now you can wait,
you can keep the debt growing and you keep extending the credit.
But we,
we,
you know,
but what I think what we're going to realize soon enough is that capitalism was
not a final system.
It was a transitional system.
We don't know what that transition is into yet,
but is like an adolescent in system.
It's like aggressive,
compulsive,
competitive,
you know,
at a certain point.
And you'd have to shift into maturity and adulthood and you have to let go of
some of that adolescent compulsion.
How important is psychedelics in this equation?
Because the best tool,
in my opinion,
to sort of calm down that those instincts,
those competitive super hyper aggressive instincts is psychedelics.
And it's,
we try most illegal things.
No,
I think that really helps.
It's awesome.
It's funny because it makes me violent when I watch it.
Really?
Why it's so fun.
So I think that psychedelics have tremendous value.
I mean,
but you know,
people always say that I'm an advocate of psychedelics.
And I suppose that's true to a certain extent.
But I also feel that it's an individual decision.
They're not for everybody.
And obviously there's still illegal and frowned upon in our society.
Right.
But,
but the fact is that one of the values of psychedelics is they kind of
decondition you from your present state of consciousness and your,
and your kind of social ideology and belief system.
You know,
there's a kind of peeling away when,
I remember the first time I took mushrooms,
one of the first experiences I had was going to a deli and buying something with
money and just finding it totally ludicrous that our culture invested so much
belief and these wrinkly brown ugly pieces of paper,
you know,
and that everybody was kind of so disconnected from their present experience and
focused on the sports or the stock ticker or all this crap and for my opinion,
you know,
so,
so I think that peeling away back to a kind of phenomenological as they say,
level of just presence of being,
that's,
that's a very powerful thing.
And we tend,
as humans,
it's very easy for us to get lost in,
in,
in abstractions and concepts.
And we take her and we then we believe in our concepts.
We think that they're real,
you know,
so the psychedelics can,
can break that,
um,
that,
that investment we've made and all these things that we think are real,
that are just abstractions and concepts.
Does it have to be either or can you enjoy a good movie and still be a person
who believes that we're evolving as a consciousness and that we are in an
adolescent state of evolution and somehow or another we're in a transitionary
period and we're all coming at Kipp,
but can't you just enjoy the x men?
I actually thought I love the x men movies or just tell him and tell him what's
called.
Movies are cool,
but TV's not.
Do you ever see walking dead?
It's pretty fucking good show man.
There's zombies and these people trying to survive.
It's fucking fun.
Sometimes I like to sit in front of something and watch some shit that somebody
created that's supposed to been an entertain me.
I don't think it has to cut your capacity for thinking and reason and logic and
original thought.
I don't think it has to.
I think you could just be fun to watch.
I think a lot of people are conditioned by,
a lot of people are weak,
but a lot of people fucking eat cheeseburgers all day and become 700.
I mean,
you know,
I,
I'm not like in a,
you know,
I don't,
I don't judge you enjoy whatever you want to enjoy.
I don't really care.
I mean,
I'm personally,
you know,
what I like are,
are kind of,
when I get excited now about popular narratives,
it's,
it's more because I see in them the seeds of part of this transformation that's
underway now.
For instance,
if you look at like a lot of the most archetypally huge stories that our culture
keeps telling us,
which includes the mutant,
you know,
the x man,
Harry Potter,
you know,
Lord of the Ring [inaudible] for a certain extent.
But,
um,
Star Wars,
let's say avatar destroy that's repeated over and over again is there's like
this hero's journey.
And as part of that hero's journey,
there has to be a learning to use our psychic faculties,
you know,
so,
uh,
the matrix,
you,
those,
we're all superheroes,
dude.
Yeah.
So,
so if you look at a Mutans,
they're going to this academy.
They have to learn how to master these power,
normal gifts.
You know,
Harry Potter,
you have to learn to cast your spells,
Star Wars,
you have to use the force.
You know,
I actually,
the more that I've thought about it and the more my own experiences have kind of
echoed some of these things,
I think that these stories are,
are,
are so powerful because they represent a kind of yearning that people have for
kind of initiatory training and extra sensory perception.
And that is something that our society has rigorously denied us.
You know?
And I think if you look at like what happens to you when you're like an
adolescent,
like let's say you're a 1520 years old,
you know,
you have this,
you,
you have this beginning and when you're young teenager you have this tremendous
sense of expectation.
You're like waiting for some transformative thing to happen to you and then it
doesn't happen.
And so instead you accept a lot of basically crappy,
degraded substitutes like dulling entertainment.
Like,
you know,
watching athletes do this and that or whatever,
rather than having gone through something that you always just know is missing
but that,
but then the culture kind of like hides it from you.
And I think that that thing that that's missing from our culture is this direct
initiatory process.
How was the culture hiding it from you though?
I,
you know,
I think the culture,
the water sort of seeks its own level and a lot of these things and a lot of
people just get lazy and don't look for it.
And this culture that's opening up right now,
experiences now or being detailed and talked about that people could never
understand before the connection that people have together through the Internet
now it's,
there's,
there's never been anything like this before.
You know,
I don't,
I don't think it's getting dumber.
I think there's always gonna be a certain amount of dumb people.
I think there's always going to be a certain lot of people who smoke cigarettes.
Totally.
Well,
I think we,
I just stopped actually recently,
which was very exciting.
Really.
You smoked cigarettes?
Pathetic.
Wow.
Just for smart guy.
No,
I know.
What the fuck is that?
You know,
I apologize.
That's ruthless it
bro.
I swear to
fuck with you because I love you because [inaudible] actually it was through
Iowasca that I stopped actually was through.
I lost what I started also to be honest,
cause there's a whole relationship between Iowasca shamanism and the Amazon and
tobacco.
That's when I first started smoking.
It was low tobacco on you,
right?
They do.
And it's also,
there's something about the tobacco and Iowasca that are very synergetic
together.
I mean it's a,
you know,
tobacco is considered a very important power plant.
Why didn't you first,
why didn't you try cigars?
We can get natural tobacco.
Tobacco,
I tried.
The guards are way function.
I mean
they're probably not the best thing for you,
but they're better for you than cigarettes.
Yeah,
isn't it?
It's all the chemicals in cigarettes that are natural American spirits.
I mean I stayed at least at that level.
It seems like it hurts me more though.
Like when I do natural spirits it's,
it's like the next day I'm coughing up black.
It's cause it's not giving you any numbing powers like slick car.
There's 590 fucking ingredients in cigarettes that by the way usually made
government approved or did anybody really
go over all those 590 you know a lobbyist,
right?
You know who the fuck went over all those ingredients and made sure that they're
all cool.
People are dying half a million a year in America alone.
Directly related to cigarette smoking.
What you were saying?
No,
a lot of people probably,
I think also feel like they did accomplish what they wanted in life.
Like I think that's,
it seems like it seems almost a negative that you say it like that because I
talked to my dad,
he's like,
fuck yeah,
this is exactly what I wanted to do with my life.
I had loved my life.
I'm happy I'm married.
I know they'll do it.
Don't you think your Dad's pretty smart?
I think.
I mean,
unless I think that's just a negative look.
I think a lot of people like what they do.
I mean,
you're going to definitely a job though.
You've got an easy job at all.
I'm not talking about me at all.
I'm talking about like my mom,
my dad,
Mike,
Everyone I grew up around with,
they all liked what they did.
Well you might've been lucky and you grew up in the Midwest and I'm offering you
is like,
you know my way of thinking about it.
Yeah.
I think he might be your friend.
No,
my personal experience growing up was like,
you know,
I fought,
there would be this amazing thing that would happen.
Right.
Have
those things,
man.
You gotta you know,
I,
I've always said that there should be some sort of a right of right of manhood
or right.
It doesn't have to be even a man who'd thing attached to like something manly or
aggressive.
I mean,
as to finding your character,
finding your limitations,
doing something extraordinary.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
you know,
some of the thinkers that I wrote about in my books talked about how cultures
need to have some type of initiatory ritual and if they don't have it
consciously constructed,
it'll end up being unconsciously,
you know,
destructive.
It'll happen through war or through destruction of the environment or something.
So,
so one,
one theory that I have about the,
you know,
quote unquote 2012 or this transition that we're in is that it's almost on an
unconscious level.
You know,
humanity has not been able to change its behavior,
right?
So it's,
it's like it's on an unconscious level.
We're kind of willing ourselves into a state of catastrophe to bring about an
initiation and thereby a transformation of consciousness.
100% sure of that,
that 94% that's strong,
man.
That's very strong.
Those are strong words.
Who knows what the fuck is going to happen?
That's what I say I say could be some sort of a meteor impact or it could be
some sort of a sky net thing.
I do believe that something is absolutely going to happen.
It's just seems to me that things are moving at such a furious pace that it just
can't last.
And I think it's a natural cycle,
man.
I really do.
I think the reason why we're having all these natural disasters,
that's a part of a natural cycle too.
Yeah.
But if you talk to my grandpa grandfather about TVs will take it.
Like he was like,
wow,
this is crazy.
Who TV was invented.
You can see TV were,
you know it's,
they probably,
it's just us living our life and then during around a certain age where we grow
up to a certain point where we're like,
yeah,
it's fucking spinning out of control.
That is back in the forties it's probably like Charlie Chaplin thought it was
spinning out of
that is possible,
but it also could be that human beings,
even though we love to think of ourselves as being separate from all the other
things in this world,
we are a natural thing and even though we have plastic fucking cars and glass
lenses for fucking cell phones even,
we are still a natural thing and we are subject to the natural cycles of this
earth,
of this super organism of the universe itself.
And even when we see crazy weather patterns and wild,
crazy shit,
there could easily also be crazy cultural patterns and that culture,
even though we can create it and we do have control of it,
it may be very well a natural movement as natural as your evolution from baby to
adulthood.
It could be a natural,
it could be what we've published.
Some uh,
could,
we will be,
make me want to fucking choke of it.
That's a good one.
On the West Mag,
it's a shirt at web magazine that I run reality Sandwich and we've been
publishing some excerpt which is not mac friendly by the way.
I want you to know that.
I don't know if you know that both of these computers,
I tried to go to your website today and just search my name obviously first,
but then Joe Rogan's name and both of them kept on crashing.
My browser crashed my browser.
No,
I've never had that problem.
I don't really know Google chrome.
Check it out.
Just one of those old Max with a track ball.
No.
I used to new Mac track balls anyway,
published a few pieces by a German scientists.
I did our brows,
wrote a book called Revolution 2012 and he's one of a bunch of people who are
arguing that a lot of what's happening,
it has to do with changes that are taking place throughout the whole solar
system to have to do with the sun changing it.
Actually the electromagnetic environment of the earth is shifting what is
supposed to be a galactic alignment on December 21st,
2012 because I've heard Neil Tyson who I very much respect who is that?
Who it,
he's a scientist,
a very famous internet scientist that sign,
I shouldn't say gain wrestler.
He's a fucking,
he's a scholar of a very well respected,
I believe he's an astrophysicist or something along those lines,
but super,
super brilliant guy.
He Poo pooed that there was any alignment whatsoever.
You said it's a constant thing.
That alignment,
that same alignment happens all the time.
He's like,
you know,
the fact that everyone's making it out to December 21st,
2012 was the first time that has happened in 25,000 years.
He's like,
that's nonsense.
And he's,
I believe he knows more than I do,
probably know for sure.
So,
I mean,
I can just give you my little meditation.
um,
my understanding is that it's simply an obstacle alignment,
which,
which means there's no particular reason that we would know of that would be
such a tremendous,
tremendous transformative thing where the winter solstice sun rises within the
dark rift at the center of the Milky Way.
So in a sense,
it's an eclipse of the center of the Milky Way by the,
by the sun on the winter solstice on that particular date.
So,
so that date had a lot of significance for them.
It was like the key moment in the year and they considered the son to be the
first father and they saw the dark rift at the center of the Milky Way as the
cosmic mother,
or they also called it apparently a black hole.
Which is interesting because only in the last like 15 years that are astronomers
discover there is a huge black hole to center of the Milky Way.
Also know that there's actually a supermassive black hole and his son are of
every single galaxy,
and that that supermassive black hole is one half of 1% of a mass of every
galaxy.
So if you have a giant galaxy,
it's a much bigger black hole.
And they even have the first photograph they've ever taken of a black hole
eating a black hole.
It's fucking crazy.